[Música]
los vendedores trabajan en cada esquina
de la capital
[Música]
en cestos o encima de periódicos en el
suelo le venden saltamontes a los
transeúntes ávidos por conseguirlos a
buen precio
estos manjares alados son un platillo
muy común para los locales
sabe parecido a la carne o incluso al
pollo
es delicioso
los saltamontes son un ingrediente
básico en uganda
muchos de estos insectos provienen de
más acá en la zona central del país
estos hombres preparan su cacería diaria
todos los días al atardecer instalan
trampas hechas de barriles y láminas de
metal corrugado
tenemos que preparar esto correctamente
para atraer muchos saltamontes o que
debemos instalarlo todos los días y
desmontarlo cada mañana
así recolectamos el contenido
cuando cae la noche del último paso es
encender las bombillas sobrecargadas que
emiten una luz cegadora y la reflejan en
las láminas
la luz es irresistible para los
saltamontes y los atrae al área
como pueden ver en el cielo los
saltamontes vienen se chocan con las
láminas de metal y caen dentro de los
barriles después esperamos hasta la
mañana para recolectar la mayor cantidad
posible
para los cazadores mojar los barriles
para impedir que los saltamontes vuelvan
a escalar hasta la superficie es un
trabajo duro ya que la luz también
afecta a los trabajadores jamás ojo mi
piel está totalmente seca por la luz de
la lámpara y por las mañanas se pela
también me duelen los ojos porque están
secos mire su piel también se está
pelando y le arden los ojos
para maximizar aún más los resultados
los cazadores queman hierba fresca para
que el humo blanco concentre la luz un
conocimiento heredado de la tradición
[Música]
en la noche de kilómetros de luz verde
ilumina en el cielo
[Música]
y al amanecer los cazadores se preparan
para la cosecha
y lo atrapamos muchos hoy aunque no sea
muy abundante lo recolectado es
suficiente para llenar decenas de
costales que pesan varios kilos tras
cargar los vehículos deben darse prisa
porque es necesario que los insectos
lleguen frescos y vivos
a tiempo para el ajetreado mercado
matutino de la capital
empiezan las primeras ventas del día los
compradores hacen un control de calidad
de los productos y luego comienza la
negociación
no hay un precio fijo un día es muy alto
al día siguiente mucho más bajo cambia
constantemente
en menos de una hora ibrahim ya vendió
todo su lote y ganó casi 860 dólares
entre tanto los vendedores siguen
llegando de todas partes del país
una vez vendidos en el mercado al precio
del día cientos de ayudantes los
preparan quitándoles las salas las patas
y la cola
luego son revendidos así listos para ser
cocinados y comidos
estoy vendiendo estos a 7000 una taza
en la tarde cuando regrese a mi casa mi
esposa nos freirá muy bien serán mi
merienda son muy sabrosos
son un platillo poco convencional en
muchas partes del mundo pero los
saltamontes son ricos en nutrientes y
contienen mucha más proteína que la
carne de res o el pescado además de los
beneficios para la salud son una fuente
de alimentación sostenible y es muy
posible que se conviertan en un
ingrediente esencial del mañana